hey Colonel Brian here my legs are
crossed that means I mean business about
our new animated show final space with
creator olan Rogers young man we're
gonna give you the inside scoop I'm just
reading off the card
I don't inside no one has said inside
spoon this is the late for me I've got
the inside scoop Oya anyway someone says
we're getting the inside scoop and we're
gonna give you some answers to some of
your questions before it premieres
tonight on TBS but first we want you to
check out this trailer
I'm afraid Gary
there is no foreseeable outcome where
you survived good morning Gary day 1818
how about freaking no you are not the
captain you are a prisoner aboard this
ship as soon as the crab hit the
interstellar fan I became a captain for
real
you're oblivious to this thing aren't
you what bat okay
what's a mooncake I'm not waiting
welcome man sits around twiddling our
wieners why would they be twiddling
their wieners as long as I draw breath
and you provide me with copious amounts
of adventure I will be there for you
we're a team now
Gary if the breach in time-space cannot
be reversed in 36 hours the earth will
be consumed I didn't really sell that
very well did I
[Applause]
you know you can't succeed you're lonely
escape there's no winning this there's
no way to cause this breach of helpers
my friends
okay but I'm not gonna leave you
what course should I send earth or
actually know the universe we're gonna
save earth earth look it's Carl Carl
how's life Carl is dead
Gary classic Carl recently homeless guy
in the corner
how final space came about this sprang
from your brain just take us through it
briefly yeah well in 2011 I created what
might be the absolute worst cartoon ever
made it was called Gary space and it was
just images moving across the screen but
I grew up watching Toonami you know
Dragon Ball Z reboot you know you know
these shows you watch them you know what
I'm down with everything you just said
hey exactly
yeah so and then in 2016 I decided I
wanted to reboot this idea and really
take it seriously and create something
that I kind of watched as a kid and and
make something see realized that had a
lot of heart and you track these
characters with their growth throughout
the whole season but yeah that's
essentially how it got started so what
happened was and people are curious
about this someone on our staff brought
your YouTube creation to me into our
production company and we saw it and I
loved it I really loved it and I thought
we could ruin this I didn't want to pass
up that chance no I actually you know my
I saw my role as don't screw this up
this so much of this show is really
already there and create the possibility
for you to make it as beautiful looking
as
I love just I noticed because I used to
work on The Simpsons but I I noticed
good direction
I think people a lot of times watch
animation they don't even think of it
being directed yeah and and how shots
are chosen and how perspectives are
illustrated and I think it's really
beautiful it's really that aful to look
at yeah I mean there's so many people
poured their heart and soul into the
show and and the directors and the
animators the storyboard is a
compositors it's it's really unique
looking show as far as the the
compositing goes I mean incorporating
real NASA space into you know a 2d
cartoon is is really really unique and
it kind of gives that beauty there's
something else that you touched on that
I there's one of the things that really
drew me into the show is just you know
animated shows can sometimes feel very
sometimes feel very superficial and
especially when there are a lot of jokes
you can feel like the jokes just rest on
the surface yeah a lot of funny jokes
what really drew me to this is there is
and I'm not I don't mean this in a corny
way but the stakes feel real to me on
this show and the the longing that
characters can have for each other or
the fear they can have and the Jeopardy
that they're in actually feels real and
there are real consequences yeah and
that I had a strong appeal to me and I
think that's been realized in the shows
that you made yeah I mean that's
something that we definitely wanted to
do was have basically a show that had
real consequences that you felt
something if something happened to a
character if their arm got ripped off
like it doesn't reset its it just stays
that way for the rest of the show and
you track you know just their growth as
characters as well from the beginning
year is just like crazy guy and by the
end of it you know he starts to become
you know more whole and more like a
person because he's been so isolated now
he's talking to people and chatting and
um yeah I mean it's it's it's definitely
something that we wanted to do which was
create real consequences and a real
threat with our villain also making
mooncake really cute yeah yeah very
smart from a marketing perspective we'll
get to that later
these are made of under percent pure USA
asbestos but no it's like there's a to
me I think there's also like Lord
Commander when you first see him you can
pass him off as he's a silly you know
because as I say the jokes land the
jokes feel funny to me but there's scene
where he reveals what he really does to
people yeah and and you see that it's
real and I thought I talked about this
week you were on my show tonight and we
were talking about my experience with my
kids watching the show with me and my
daughter's 14 of my son's 12 and they I
could see that they were really drawn in
by they thought that show was funny but
they also got the sense that wait a
minute these are real people yeah and I
want their they got invested pretty
quickly yeah in the first episode they
wanted to see the second then they
wanted to see the third and I thought
that was a good sign and they've been
begging me I haven't been able to show
them all the shows yet because they've
been color correcting yeah doing all the
stuff that you guys do in animation and
I keep saying you know they're like dad
I want to see that stuff I'm like no no
I'm rich and a celebrity is crying your
needs aren't important to me like please
wait you know emotionally cruel to mom
or whatever they really are invested in
it yeah and forget the other stuff I
said about my marriage so I don't know
you know how are you feeling about you
know you started out on YouTube and now
I know that we've shown some of these
trailers in giant movie theaters yeah
have you had that experience of seeing
this in a movie theater not yet it's
pretty amazing my kids came back from
again they were seeing a movie they were
seeing a nine and a half weeks and
director's cut because we want them to
see you know classy porn and no but they
came back from the theater and they were
doing we saw we saw it and I know that
this would look beautiful up on a big
screen oh yeah I mean it's it's I wish
everybody could watch it with surround
on a massive screen because ice it's
it's definitely meant to be washed that
way and it's it's meant to be binge
tanned yeah well I'll definitely have to
get your kids the the next couple
episodes yeah that would seem important
want this relationship to continue who's
the character you you brought me in to
do some voices and I was surprised
because I did no preparation
that is how I prepare yeah that is a
Buddhist monk surely before he died went
to taught and told me once that the way
to prepare is not to prepare and so I
didn't know what I was going to be doing
and I went in and I but on the spot
there's a character that says that cells
sort of deals in the underground and he
has to sell a suit made of flesh and
disguise himself and so I think you were
giving me some coaching about what it is
you wanted this guy to be yeah and I
think I just ripped off Peter Lorre
I don't even know if anyone's gonna know
Peter Lorre who's watching now because
there's two circles there's the internet
and there's people who know who Peter
Lorre there's no intersection but he's
in old 1930s and 40s movies saying yes
he's this and so I sort of did a little
bit of that but I Cameron what else I
did what I thought was a very effective
character and they'd be the most
powerful character on the show yeah I
mean life just went out of you pretend
he's ah he's a great character yeah such
a staple you know in the show it just
did a fantastic job thank you that's all
I want with that and to see a few more
there he is I think they have a shot of
him there is that him with goggles on
anyway I don't think I was paid for that
do what I don't know I'm having my
accountants look into it looking about
it there's a lot about this final space
thing which is very shady this is like a
scam you're running we have time for
some questions here JM
cam from YouTube asks can space really
be final though we need to be high do
you have any answers for that one no
you're gonna have to watch the show yo
gotta watch so to figure that out yeah
your voice gets high when you lie
sebastian st. from facebook asks will
this be airing in canada and if so on
what channel i don't know you got to ask
that and i don't know why is that all
responsibility can people are watching
canada I have no idea anymore I mean I
you know I know they get the internet
and a TBS Jeff what's going on with TBS
in Canada okay
wait they Reaper cost rebroadcast which
the the Conan show okay yeah but we're
worried about no one cares online right
now by the Conan show they care about
this is the level this is a good
education for everyone watching right
now the level of sophistication the show
is great but then it's just a bunch of
hobos in Rome that don't know what's
good I'm sure you can see it in Canada
and you know what I think is Canadians
it's your right to be able to see all
the shows that we enjoy here in the
United States right the dream right
there that's the dream and that's the
way to bring the world together you
shouldn't just see our current shows you
should get to see like chips from the
70s and family affair no I'm not
breathing
[Laughter]
maryanne madman io from facebook asks
where can we get moon cake there's three
left there's only three three one cakes
left and I'm supposed to mention this
for a chance to win one of these moon
cakes follow at team cocoa on Instagram
all this week now like I say there are
only three we don't know if we're gonna
make more but they're beautiful they're
soft they're soft there's a creepy
sexuality to that one yes just this one
these ones are fun it's just this one
Lisa used to be breast implants he's
been repurposed so nothing was wasted
but yes follow us and you two can have a
moon cake and we're getting the odor
we're getting rid of that don't worry
about it okay
tea super silly on YouTube asks how many
episodes in this season 110 episodes 10
episodes that was an easy one that was
so much easier than kin space really be
final
Brianna mercury from facebook says
should I watch every week or wait to
binge this show what do you think what
would you do oh man I'm a bender but at
the same time you know I guess it helps
the show if it's watched every week do
you know I don't know every week watch
it every week do think the answer is to
binge it and watch it every idea and
then watch the commercials and buy
everything that is sold during the
commercials and then write those
products and say I only bought your
product because a final space that's the
huckster in me don't listen to me that's
cynical and shallow okay emo Charlie 88
from periscope I love this guy who is
your favorite character of all the
characters uh for me personally probably
their mood kicker tribe or why is that
why my tribe or I don't know he's he
comes back in a big way at the end of
the season and it's it's really funny
it's like something that you would not
expect that character coming back as
okay what about you I like the character
I played I thought I was the only voice
on the show that really brought a
character to life 9 dimension you're
great you you are great in a very
functional way
yeah but I thought I six dimensions with
me 9 with you 9 with me you just wait'll
you see me pop up in this show selling a
suit made of skin okay Tanya Zee from
YouTube wants to know where did Owen
Rogers get his socks
well these guess where Trader Joe's was
it yeah is it Trader Joe's Oh what
Trader Joe's trick those regret I know
but there's a putt sometimes sometimes I
have one of those carousels where they
try and get you to buy something it's
not really Trader Joe's e at the end of
trip adjustable yeah you know I don't
see anything like that
all right now just target goat or J you
like Target huh I just got socks I don't
like my good I remember let me see the
socks those are fantastic you can get
those at Target Jeff just target
advertise on our show yes Oh Target
fantastic company amazing company I love
Target we all love Target go to Target
now and then Peter
sahan from Facebook where did you get
your inspiration from mooncake a very
unusual character yeah mooncake was they
I always wanted to do a chewy have a
chewy sidekick that's cool that's
mooncake what I like about mooncake is
the disparity between mood Cakes
appearance and what moon cake can
actually do yeah I think it was a nice
surprise in the first first episode I
just like that this is the destroyer of
worlds the ultimate thing that everyone
fears and it's the most cuddly sweet
beautiful piece of merchandising oh
here's a question Francis Hernandez from
facebook says well final space have a
panel or be involved in SDCC this year I
have no idea what do you think again
they're asking questions that we're not
qualified to answer we're like two guys
that work behind the counter at Evarts
rent-a-car who don't rent cars you're
asking us about the paneled wagon and
we're like I don't know Jeff you have
any answers to that question no answer
yes Jeff in the background okay oh this
is a good question a trusty boys from
periscope love rusty boys - are there
any other celebs featured and yes there
are yeah there's a tika Sumpter got Fred
Armisen David Tennant Ron Perlman Steven
Yeun who else Keith David Leonardo
DiCaprio place two guys two voices
that's what's that Oh Jeff just got an
answer and yes he did get his table
[Laughter]
whenever you hear redirecting Canadians
it sounds scary redirect the Canadians
redirect them ah I reads from twitch
Conan what prompted you to want to take
this project on what made it stand out I
think we sort of touched on that already
but I do obviously I'm a fan of
animation going way back to my Simpsons
days and my childhood and I really I
loved that this show it's a rare
combination of it's funny but there's an
emotional core to it and when you can
get the two of them working at the same
time which I think the Simpsons has
managed to do he's a very rare thing and
I think this show has that and that was
the appeal for me and so that's pretty
easy heather from youtube i was at the
premiere in Nashville this weekend
amazing job olan what was it like
working with bigger actors like Conan
and David actor actor I don't know are
you do you consider yourself an actor no
that was an actor would I be doing this
every night kissing a beautiful woman on
screen and now in punching a guy and
then saving Earth from a meteor no one
cares what is it chaplains answer what's
that sdcc yes
SDCC positive that sounds like a
diagnosis okay oh that it for questions
we're out of time okay all right how
long does it take to animate the show oh
geez it took a whole year yeah takes a
year it takes a year the slide a long
time yeah so put down your vape pen you
know and get to work it takes a long
time final space premieres tonight at
10:30 on TBS you can find the first
three episodes on TBS dot-com and on the
TBS app give it a try
check it out first taste is free are we
done here we wrapping it up
Owen congratulations you're a very
talented funny nice person oh thanks for
joining us